the Golden Globes is a party and nearly
every celebrity in Hollywood is invited
but it seems a certain contagious
disease made its way onto the guest list
as well keep watching to find out who
won't be attending any events for a
while and instead will be back at home
it seems that this year's Awards season
is not going quite as planned on January
10 2023 the 80th Golden Globe awards
took place to celebrate the best of film
and television from the previous year
after last year's less than Stellar show
that saw the Golden Globes go for a
hybrid style of part to zoom and part in
person presentation this year's event
brought things back to a more
traditional and welcome manner the
prestigious ceremony saw some pretty
major events take place from kihui
Kwan's wholesome best supporting actor
win for everything everywhere all at
once to Eddie Murphy's Cecil B Demille
award win and subsequent speech that
referenced another notable awards
ceremony moment but as with every year
the Globes couldn't escape from having
some less than pleasing moments bogged
down the festivities this year's show
brought the ceremony to its lowest
ratings yet and continues to see contra
diversity from within the industry most
notably with the whale star Brendan
Fraser skipping out on the event as an
active protest Entertainment Weekly
reported to top it all off it seems that
several of those who were in attendance
took home something far less desirable
than a golden statue following this
year's Golden Globe ceremony an uptick
in covid-19 cases has been spreading
among some of the night's attendees
first to report being infected was Jamie
Lee Curtis who received a nomination for
best supporting actress for her role in
everything everywhere all at once the
Halloween star took to Instagram on
January 13th where she wrote covid sadly
this head cheerleader is not going to be
at all the weekend festivities cheering
on her friends and colleagues life's On
Life's terms Curtis also shared that as
a result of the positive test she will
not be able to attend either the bafta
Tea Party or Critics Choice Awards
despite being nominated for the latter
ceremony not long after the Banshees of
innishear and stars Colin Farrell and
Brendan Gleason were also said to have
contracted covid-19 according to the
Hollywood Reporter the event saw
inashiran as the night big winner with
Farrell nabbing a win for best Motion
Picture actor in a musical or comedy
Martin McDonough getting a win for best
screenplay and the film itself winning
best musical or comedy motion picture
for The Hollywood Reporter the covid-19
diagnosis also means that neither actor
will be appearing at the Critics Choice
Awards so what will happen at upcoming
Awards shows likely not much the news of
actors such as these Contracting
covid-19 following their appearance at
the Golden Globes highlights the reality
that we are still not fully out of the
covid-19 pandemic while vaccines and
other medical breakthroughs have helped
the world readjust over the last few
years there are still times of the year
when the danger is more present such was
the case for the Golden Globes not long
before the event LA Public Health issued
a recommended 10-day mask policy as
people transition back into work and
school the Golden Globe Ceremony this
year however largely seemed to abandon
this mindset with the only major
attendees seen wearing a mask being
Jessica Chastain to some this might
cause concerns for the upcoming 95th
academy awards ceremony although it's
more than likely that Curtis feral
Gleason and any other Golden Globe
attendees who contracted covid-19 will
recover by the time the Oscar ceremony
occurs on March 12 2023 should the
academy be too relaxed with their
pandemic protocols we could see another
string of six celebrities follow up the
event thankfully the Academy's safety
measures from last year's event seemed
to have worked out as no major news came
out regarding confirmed cases only time
will tell how the results of this year's
Globes will affect safety precautions at
other Awards shows in the coming months
[Music]